build-it draw play Vsauce Kevin here
with some of the coolest creations from
extraordinary people this is beauty
people building shweta builds kinetic
insects lamps the shiny biomorphic
insects flutter and glow using motors
and LEDs and he considers his moving
sculptures to be living things in which
every piece has its place and after it
eventually breaks down the pieces can be
dismantled and reused as a type of
rebirth Lori Nix makes post-apocalyptic
dioramas she meticulously builds
landscapes and architectural interiors
and then photographs them without any
digital manipulation she mixes a wide
variety of materials like foam board
clay paper acrylic paint plaster wood
tiny figurines and organic materials
like real leaves punched through leaf
shaped holes and she creates them in her
small apartment in New York City
Kendra haste creates huge animals out of
galvanized wire she goes on wild
expeditions like tracking Tigers in
India or following wildebeest migrations
in Tanzania and then makes the
sculptures based on individual animals
she encounters the unique portraits are
first drawn on paper and then she uses
the wire to bring them into the third
dimension draw Josiah Brooks makes
animations tutorials and speed paintings
on his youtube channel draw with Jazza
the Australian will teach you everything
from painting and Photoshop to different
animating techniques like how to animate
a transformation even as a series of
videos just about the creative process
to provide advice and motivation for
budding artists Judith Braun creates
wall murals by finger painting with
charcoal dust she explores symmetrical
designs as well as textured landscapes
though brawn typically painstakingly
plans her pieces in advance she was
recently diagnosed with breast cancer
which has influenced her to take a more
improvisational approach and she abides
by three rules symmetry abstraction and
carbon medium and now for the hyper
collage architecture of Jim Kazanjian
made out of up to 50 composited images
[Music]
[Music]
Micro Venice is a bento box fanatic and
focuses his food creations mostly on
Disney characters his Instagram account
om Curie's showcases dozens of colored
rice creations ranging from Tigger and
professor Ratigan to a few non Disney
characters like Princess Bubblegum and
puppycat playing Paula noid director Jan
Bitzer used a setup of lasers and
mirrors to animate islands of glass by
Barcelona musician rob plow samurai
guitarist makes inventive guitar based
videos here's his version of Kentucky
jelly by Brad Paisley using a banjo
Telecaster acoustic guitar washboard and
spoons mandolin and acoustic bass
[Music]
finally the video for Raiders by French
band sound crawler draws from Star Wars
dune and Mad Max
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration also comes from you
Vsauce creative fan showcase first up is
adept with early winter morning let's go
[Music]
Jordan Clayton is a Canadian visual
artist that specializes in paintings
that focus on the science and
understanding of phenomena his most
recent work explores fungal and
bacterial growth
David Lechner creates wooden sculptures
using driftwood pulled out of a local
River in Austria the 17 year old began a
carpentry apprenticeship and has since
been using his newfound skills to create
sculptures here's the digital
photography of Shahir Akbar nice who
performs three original songs behind the
San Diego Convention Center West was
paralyzed from the neck down during a
motocross accident and uses a head mouse
extreme to create designs for his
clothing brand for 1/7 Emile's Leaguers
is a 3d environment artist from the
netherlands he hopes to get a full-time
job in the gaming industry and recently
recreated part of the university
environment from the Last of Us while
over in Australia Daniel Rutherford
designs and models mecha weapons
characters and other sci-fi stuff with
3ds max leo frederick has a series of
daily improv piano videos here's his
take on m83
Rihanna and imagine dragons
[Music]
stephane purses an architect from
Romania who bends copper wire into
different creations he just recently
completed this set of copper insects and
bonny John drew a Pokemon a day often
using completely different styles and
you can find the complete set on his
website so make your beady bees to be DP
at Vsauce comm or share them with
everyone on Twitter with hashtag bidipi
and as always thanks for watching
you